what's going on guys this is Rob and I
figured I'd give a shot and another one
of these rundown videos again I hadn't
done this for a while and I was kind of
curious to see whether or not people
would still be interested in this those
of you guys who don't know the rundown
is basically where I'm just like here's
a thing that happens in a comic
somewhere you know and it's cool and I
like it so I'm going to tell you guys
about it now we're supposed to do a
video on the history of the DC Universe
like the history of the mobile cinematic
universe but the history of the DC
Universe the dude guys their universe is
an absolute nightmare and like I've been
up since 5:30 in the morning I've been
sitting here for seven hours trying to
get it sorted out and so it's gonna take
me a long time to do so in order to get
this done the way I need it to be left
to take like two weeks and sort through
all of DC's nonsense because I don't
even think they know how their universe
works and I'll have to go through all
the crises and all I kind of stuff and
it's gonna be a great big huge pain in
the butt but while I'm doing that I
figured I would talk about something
cool and I figured what better way to
bring back the run down the talk about
how for fought apocalypse so in Marvel
Comics among certain circles of older
fans who like characters aren't relevant
there is a villain named King the
Conqueror and King the conquer is
basically just a dick this is a guy that
just travels back and forth true through
time just like being mean to people he
just he just goes back and forth through
Tom he's just like you know I'm just
gonna be mean to the Fantastic Four
because I'm came to conquer and I'm a
dick and that's what I do so because of
the fact that he bounces back and forth
in time all the time he's everywhere
like he literally shows up everywhere in
Marvel Comics and it's absolutely insane
now with regards to this whole story if
you guys are looking online origin on
apocalypse my video talking about his
whole thing and I've got multiple videos
explaining all that apocalypse is like
the second Newton ever bore the first
one was Selene those of you guys who
were really old comic fans are gonna
tell me that I'm wrong you're wrong I'm
right Selene was like the first mutant
or she is mutant kind of mutant whatever
she has to drain people's lifeforce to
stay alive who cares anyway so
apocalypse shows up and he's in Egypt
and yada yada he falls in love with a
chick named two fury she rejects him
he's like barred his powers manifests in
a fit of jealousy and then he starts
cutting a swath through society and
ruling everything all right done and
done so anyway during the time when
apocalypse was in Egypt he was being
tracked down by Kang the Conqueror
because Kane the Conqueror was like
from the future and if I make Apocalypse
you know my error if I can control him I
can control the future because
apocalypse is destined to be like super
powerful
well apocalypse had basically overthrown
Cana conquerors sent him running for his
life but ever since then came the
Conqueror was always trying to find a
way to make apocalypse as error and
control him which is a stupid idea
because quema conquer can't do that he's
a regular guy that travels back and
forth through time but for those of you
guys who never read Avengers vs. x-men
this was a story that was written as a
clickbait story that Marvel sold because
they knew people would buy it and they
couldn't buy anything else good at the
time so they wrote this story where it
was like the Phoenix force was coming
back to earth and Cyclops of the Exton
was like yeah the Phoenix force is
coming back maybe I'll get to see gee
maybe I won't I don't know but it's
probably gonna take over like Hope
Summers because she's gonna be a
harbinger for the Phoenix force she's
destined to or something like that
and Captain America and the Avengers are
like oh my god dude if the Phoenix force
comes back and it takes ahold of Hope
Summers and mutants would be really
powerful again and then they could like
overthrow humanity or something like
that and so what is it happening is the
Avengers in the x-men fight one another
Captain America is like hey Cyclops you
need to give us Hope Summers and Cyclops
is like nope and so they end up fighting
one another for a while now after
Avengers vs. x-men was finished she had
the Phoenix 5 and all that kind of stuff
which doesn't matter to our discussion
here but once Avengers vs. x-men was
finished Captain America formed the
Avengers unity squad and this was
basically just Marvel saying hey our
sales are slumping nobody's buying our
let's just like combine the x-men
and the Avengers together and see what
happens so we got uncanny Avengers but
this was actually a really cool concept
and it was a really cool line of comics
up until it wasn't what ended up
happening what did it up happening is
Marvel came up with this genius idea of
the apocalypse twins they're like hey
what if like arc angel knocked up a
chick and then she gave birth to his
kids like he's had a huge history with
apocalypse looks like have those kids
become apocalypse twins so Warren
Worthington chick gives birth to kids
came to conquer kidnaps the kids and
then brainwashes and they become the
apocalypse twins whatever so within the
whole Thor landscape this whole Thor
mythology Asgard all that kind of stuff
you've got the hammer Mjolnir which is
like Thor's that-that's-that's Thor's
main girl all right that's Thor's like
I'm bringing the hammer
you know and then you've got yarn born
young Berlin is the axe that Thor used
before he ever had neo Mir this is like
a mystical enchanted axe that was
created by the doors that can basically
cut through anything but the problem is
for put it somewhere and came the
conquer doesn't know where he put it
so in order to solve this problem came
the conquer travels into the past to
like 1013 ad and he goes and finds
apocalypse and he's like hey apocalypse
dude I know that you have like your
celestial armor now like you have your
godly armor and you got your godly
powers you can shape-shift and do all
the stuff that makes you really really
cool even though you can't defeat you
know grew a group as triplet is the
x-men like I know you've got all this
really really cool stuff like Thor's
gonna kill you like Thor is going to you
know making it so you can't rule the
future man and you should probably do
something about that and so apocalypse
is like oh my god yes like I need to
rule the future and we got to stop we
have stuff for so he goes and he finds
Thor in Scandinavia now originally we
didn't know that came to conquer was
behind all this instead Thor's just like
drinking and having like an amazing it
looks like the best time ever like what
he's doing right now like he's having an
amazing time he's drinking alcohol and
he's like singing songs and he's like
I'm Thor and like he's just beating
people up and stuff like that like it
looks amazing like if I mean if I were
Thor I would do that to be honest like I
would do what Thor is doing right now
you know drinking and beating people up
but then like apocalypse shows up and he
was like your day is done and then he
just like humbles Thor you know and he's
like get out of my face and like hips
Thor send them flying out of the room
alright and the two of them just
basically start going out and now Thor's
got your army won and so he's like man
we need to like I need to take out I
take out this guy whoever this guy
happens to be like he hits me from
behind you know and that's not okay and
so apocalypse starts like attacking and
the two of them are going at each other
and like the axe is hitting apocalypse
and nothing's happening and so Thor's
like man dude like I got to do something
man so like Thor bails
alright Thor is just like peace and he
gets out of there so then he takes off
back to back to Asgard and so all this
is happening apocalypse teleports back
to his vessel thing and he meets up with
Kang the Conqueror and he's like hey man
look like you know what in the heck is
going on here and Kang's like yeah I do
trust me man you got to kill him you
know and then everything will be cool
and so we we pick up
alright so we're in Asgard now thorns
back here on you know from the Rainbow
Bridge and he goes and he talks to Odin
he's like hey look Odin man like there's
this dude that showed up on earth and
like he kicked my ass and I need
something to be able to beat this dude
and Odin's like hey look Thor I know
you're my son you know you're cool you
know I'm Anthony Hopkins you need to
chill out
alright like do not let this dude get
the better of you just let things go
just let him be a dick it's basically
like every parents answer to a kid
that's being bullied like you know
sticks and stones may break your bones
and apocalypse probably kill you but you
need to let it go and so Thor is like no
man we need to do something about this
so Loki's like ha ha this is my chance
to be an so Loki is like hey
like you should go and look up this
scroll that will enchant your axe so it
can cut through celestial armor and it
can like damage up hakka lives and so
Thor's like yes you know I know how to
read a little bit and so he starts
talking to so it's going over this this
scroll it starts reading it and he takes
it and he gets his he gets his action
chanted but then we actually learn that
in truth it is Kang the Conqueror
disguise as Loki who is basically
tricked Thor into enchanting his action
so while for is in Asgard apocalypse is
like ok look like this dude just ran off
riding a carriage being pulled by some
horses he flew into the sky whatever man
I've seen crazier stuff before so he's
like we got to find some way to get Thor
to come back to me so that I can kill
him and not have to worry about not
being able to take over the future so
apocalypse like gathers his horsemen
because he's always got a horseman
already had a horse from this time he
always has worse been forever all right
and so he shows up they show up in
London and the horsemen start like
attacking everybody all right they're
attacking guards on a bridge
they're attacking regular people they're
attacking cows all right don't ask your
wife house is alive in 1013 ad that's
just way too so they're attacking
everybody all right in Thor shows up and
throws like note we're not even putting
up with this today like I'm literally
gonna kill you all and the horse were
like oh my god what's going on this guy
is just like attacking us with the
magical ax and and we have no clue
what's going on right now but they don't
really say that because they're all too
busy being dead now while this is
happening and all the horsemen are just
getting totally obliterated by Thor like
apocalypse is watching all this unfold
and apocalypse is like wait a minute
like he used that action on me earlier
and
axé did not work why is he killing my
horseman now so he turns around a came
to conquer and he's like hey dude what's
going on man like this is not cool
alright that Thor is killing my horseman
right now this is not how things are
supposed to be what in the hell's going
on Mae Kang's like hey man like that's
just how it goes and then he just pieces
out alright so came the Congress is like
bah and just bails this whole time like
apocalypses pissed so he's just like
throwing shade at king the conquer like
he's mad as hell alright so Thor ends up
coming back to the realm to the ship of
apocalypse and it's just like hey man
your time has come like you hit B in the
back earlier and I'm not okay with being
hit from behind and that's really what
I'm upset about the most all right so he
starts attacking apocalypse and
apocalypse is like hey man I ain't
worried about you all right like you
know forth roses axe apocalypse catches
it he's like dude I've got the powers of
a god all right I can shape-shift you
know I can pretend to be an old man in
the x-man cartoon show I can do all
kinds of cool stuff alright I'm not
worried about you and Thor's like oh
yeah and so like he hits the hammer into
apocalypse in the pocket was like what
the hell just happened alright and so
like apocalypse was freaking out and he
was like you just know this this doesn't
make any sense
like I'm understand how you kill or how
you how you managed injure me and Thor's
like hey man Asgardian magic dude like I
told you you know you're messing with
wrong one but you didn't want to listen
you know and so Thor's just like I'll
leave you to be defeated because I
worried about you because now I've
gotten the magical ax
that can like cut your head off if I
wanted to and so he leaves you know
apocalypse to do his own thing and the
ship self-destructs and blows up
and so Thor's like okay cool I guess I
don't have to worry about that now
because apocalypse is dead so cut to
Asgard alright so Thor's like
celebrating his whole victory he's like
yeah man like I beat up this dude who
was like I had like got armor and stuff
like that because I'm Thor you know and
hey ladies ladies like you know Thor
like hey kill to God over here I'm a
beast let's go upstairs
but then like Odin bust em and Odin
psyche dude what in the hell have you
done and Thor's like huh what what's
going on and Odin's like you do have no
idea how bad you screwed up like you
literally just screwed up everything
all right like the future is is
is messed up because of you like you've
literally just doomed like people in the
future at some point in time you know
that we don't know exactly what happened
but a bad thing will happen because of
what you've done come to find out Kane
the Conqueror had engineered this in
order to acquire your imbuing
alright so like he didn't know we're for
he put it after it was all said and done
and so he finds out that Thor had put
you on bjorn in some cave belonging to
Baron Mordo because he had fought him at
some point in time I don't remember why
but he basically fought him and left it
there and so came to conquer just like
all right awesome cool I got you on buin
and then he goes off and does his own
thing which leads to a really stupid
story but nonetheless that's basically
how you know Thor fought apocalypse I
like it I thought it was really really
cool let me know what you guys think and
yeah so I will catch you guys later
peace